Americans love democracy except when it
comes to voting the u.s. came in nearly
last in a recent ranking of 35 developed
countries for voter turnout and the 2014
midterm elections only 36% of eligible
Americans voted the lowest turnout in
more than 70 years the 2012 presidential
election was higher but still not great
fifty three point six percent of
eligible Americans voted so is there
something the US can learn from other
countries France and Sweden both ranked
higher on the list than the United
States and it might be thanks to their
automatic voter registration system
France automatically registers citizens
when they turn 18
while Sweden and other Scandinavian
countries use tax registration
information to produce a national
database of voters a few US states have
adopted some form of automatic voter
registration Vermont Oregon California
and West Virginia and many more have
considered it but efforts have installed
Australia however takes things a step
further federal elections have been
mandatory for nearly a century and the
results are impressive 95% of the voting
age population participated in the 2016
federal election and that includes
almost 87 percent of all 18 to 24 year
olds Australia also holds its elections
on Saturdays so they don't conflict with
the workweek in fact the majority of
countries hold their general elections
on weekends in the u.s. people vote on a
Tuesday which works great if you're a
19th century farmer but for those of us
living in the 21st century with 95 s not
so much the Election Day issue has
caught the attention of both Bernie
Sanders and President Barack Obama who
have called for making it a national
holiday in the u.s. Sanders went as far
as proposing legislation for a quote
democracy day in Congress that would
have given Americans the time and
opportunity to vote but the bill
received no support and was never put to
a vote another country the US could look
to for inspiration India voter turnout
in India's 2014 election set a record at
66 point four percent and voting isn't
even mandatory on a national
it's partly thanks to a culture they
created many Indians have a strong sense
of civic duty and government initiatives
like national voters day have helped
it's a day dedicated to celebrating
voters and encouraging young people to
register but they also have the benefit
of not having to go to work most
companies and businesses closed for the
day or at the very least allow employees
time to go to the polls and the good
news is that this idea is catching on in
the US tech companies like Spotify and
square are taking the leak by giving
their employees time off to go vote but
there are other ways to help more voters
cast ballots and we can start by not
making it so difficult for so many
Americans several states have adopted
strict voter ID laws to end voter fraud
but critics say these laws
disenfranchise young people African
Americans and the poor
so with these obstacles that already
stand in the way of American voters will
the u.s. ever be able to match voter
turnout in other countries